like the five to five thousand
milligrams of THC video and I was just
really tired wait you ate five thousand
yeah like when I say oh my channel I do
mad challenges like I smoked what popped
my YouTube off as I smoked a 40 gram
joint in one sitting no water no nothing
looked at the camera for two and a half
hours smoked that whole [__] thing
down because somebody said I would I
wouldn't do it oh no I saw a bunch of
YouTubers like smoking a zip holy [__]
I'm like he didn't smoke a sit by
yourself and they didn't so I [__] I'm
gonna do it by myself I'm not doing real
time in real time didn't move and ever
that video popped off I was like damn
this wolf really did smoke that oh my
God and I really I mean you watch it I
uh it was the worst I caught up tar and
[__] for like like two months probably
oh my God it was bad it hurts my life
[__] yeah it was tight it was fire ass
OG packs that I was getting at the time
too so I was very happy about that